le royaume uni at il payé pour mettre
fin à l'asile politique de julian
assange
dans des documents déclassifiés du
ministère britannique des affaires
étrangères
on apprend qu'en mars 2018 la première
ministre
theresa may a reçu l'ordre je cite de
passer la pommade aux présidents de
l'équateur le but le pousser à expulser
le journaliste australien de l'ambassade
d'équateur à londres où il s'était
réfugié depuis 2012 pour y parvenir une
véritable campagne de lobbying a été
mise en place par le gouvernement mais
qui n'a pas hésité à dépenser 20 mille
livres en 2018 pour faire venir au
royaume-uni des responsables équatoriens
dans le ministre de la défense le
ministère des affaires étrangères
organise régulièrement des réunions avec
des ministres et des fonctionnaires
d'autres pays pour encourager un
engagement plus étroits avec nos
partenaires internationaux et aider à
atteindre nos objectifs de politique
étrangère dans le cadre de ce travail
certains des coûts de ces visites sont
occasionnellement couverts par le
ministère ou par les postes ces demandes
sont soigneusement examinée au cas par
cas et uniquement lorsque des ressources
sont disponibles campagne qui a
finalement abouti le 11 avril 2019 avec
l'arrestation de julian a soudain le jeu
est lancé on me dit qu'assange va sortir
de l'ambassade d'équateur aujourd'hui on
s'attendait à ce casse en chant très
vite après l'arrivée des policiers mais
des messages envoyés à la salle des
opérations ont révélé qu'il avait causé
une certaine agitation et qu'il criait
et braille et en s'approchant du bureau
de l'ambassadeur et qu'il a été maîtrisé
de force puis avec une précision
militaire
six policiers se sont avancés pour
s'aligner de chaque côté des marches de
l'entrée afin de former un corridor de
protection par lequel assange a été
emmené vers 10h20 il a fallu de nombreux
mois de patientes négociations
diplomatiques et finalement tout s'est
déroulé sans accroc sans accroc excepté
peut-être pour un julian assange et la
liberté de la presse au royaume uni le
fondateur de wikileaks est depuis
deux ans incarcéré dans la prison
britannique de belmarsh et ses
conditions de détention sont
régulièrement dénoncé par ses avocats
mais aussi par les nations unies le fait
que julian soit toujours en prison
compromet gravement la capacité du
royaume uni de proclamer qu'il défend la
liberté de la presse dans le monde
entier
le sort de julian assange ne semble pas
beaucoup intéressé les gouvernements
occidentaux
le fondateur de wikileaks attend son
procès en appel concernant son
extradition vers les etats-unis où il
risque 175 ans de prison du fait d'une
centaine de chefs d'inculpation en vertu
des lois anti espionnage
on lui reproche notamment d'avoir mis en
lumière les agissements de l'armée
américaine en irak et en afghanistan
julian assange finalement puni pour
avoir peut-être trop bien fait son
travail de journaliste